[Music]
what disappoints you about your father
oh my god oh that's me i would pass
well it looks like the blue balls have
appeared we just went from happy dicks
to ding-dongs what disappoints me about
my father chill what i'm saying about my
childhood
national television
uh there's nothing that disappoints my
phone
what's that mean national television
that's that's good that's everything
you're saying here is going to be
[Laughter]
she's just trying to help me
don't kill her she was trying to remind
me that i'm not to say something
[Laughter]
nothing bad but i'm trying to look for
something don't go to the dark side well
if we're gonna if this is not gonna be
fun let's stop it cause i don't wanna
yeah i don't know yeah let's get out the
danglings again no no no no we're good
i'm gonna go in the other room i don't
want to turn this into like a
battleground it was just meant to be fun
dorinda definitely is about drama i
don't know if this is real dorindo if
she's just trying to like make her mark
like piss on all of us like this is my
house i'm going to storm out like
lifting her leg all the time like this
it could be what do i hate about my dad
the fact that he's getting older yeah
because he used to be
let's see
maybe to you because you may run your
life like that but this is a game
this is a game thank god brandi stopped
me how could dorinda be mad at brandy
for making me stop it's probably because
if you don't do what dorinda wants
dorinda's going after you
the end
this is a game i know jill i i know you
don't i know jill i've known joe for
over 20 years okay
so i know jared she would never say
anything bad about it she was about to
oh okay but you're nice i was thinking
and then you know what rarity you run
the game you get a game we're gonna play
cause i particularly don't like put the
ring on the deck i told you i had a
problem with that kitchen
[Applause]
because this is a game are you being
negative i just looked at the time and i
realized we haven't had a blow up today
so
one should be coming in three
two
dorinda
the dornado
because i want to know where we go wrong
here no because you were being indented
no okay
okay
here we go no no
face of an angel mouth of a serpent here
we go wow the face everything you get
out of a serpent
oh no that's okay let's just all laugh
it off i'm so confused right now because
jarinda is coming after me for no reason
it's her way or the highway and i don't
subscribe to that i'm sorry
[Music]
you